Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Decent. I'm your host as always Ricard Loup.
And today I'm joined for a second time by Doctor
Luis Favela, associate Professor of Philosophy and Cognitive Sciences
at the University of Central Florida. And today we're
talking about his book, The Ecological Brain Unifying The
Sciences of Brain, body and Environment. And by
the way, I'm leaving a link to our first
interview in the description box down below which is which
to a certain extent is also relevant to the interview
today. So Doctor Favela, welcome back to the
show. It's always a pleasure to talk to you
. Thank you Ricardo. I appreciate the invitation looking
forward to it. So I, I mean,
the way I would like to go through things here
today is that uh first of all, I would
like to get into what ecological psychology and neuroscience are
because those are the two main disciplines that you explore
in the book and also the relationship between them and
how they historically sort of came apart theoretically, methodologically
and so on and then get into the framework that
you bring into the book that you present there that
perhaps can bring them back together and perhaps other aspects
of our psychology. And so to start off with
what is ecological psychology? Really? Yeah. So
I think when, um, people hear the term
ecological psychology, I think if they think of anything
they think of, um, psychology related to the
environment. And so commonly when I talk to people
, they've said, oh, so you study,
uh how productive people are depending on what color their
room is. So if their room is painted red
, then that means the ecology causes them to be
angry and agitated. And I'm like, well,
maybe, but that's not what we mean here in
this case. So, uh when I say ecological
psychology, I'm referring to a tradition and perceptual psychology
uh that originates with James Gibson in the mid 20th
century around the 19 fifties. Um And also with
his uh spouse Eleanor Gibson, also around at the
same time. So ecological psychology was a bit of
a reaction to um the uh more popular um or
increasingly popular approaches to perception uh around the mid 20th
century. And so around that time, you had
something called the cognitive revolution. And so the cognitive
revolution was pushing back against uh behaviorist approaches. And
so behaviorism in the late 18 hundreds, early 19
hundreds argued that um if there's anything to, to
a mind or to be mental, really, what
matters for a scientific study of that is what can
be observed in behavior. And so the idea was
we can try to explain even the most complex behaviors
by things like a, a reflex or stimulus response
uh rules um that an organism develops over its lifetime
or even over eve evolutionary time scales, the cognitive
revolution came along and said, well, that's,
you know, kind of interesting and you can explain
a lot of stuff that way, but there seems
to be a lot of mental things happening that you
can't explain just by looking at the environment and then
the, the response that the organism has. And
so Noam Chomsky has this famous pushback argument against behaviorism
uh where he said, um the environment is too
impoverished, it's too poor with information for uh example
, language learning. So an infant that's starting to
learn language, um even if it's exposed much of
the day to his parents talking and family talking,
that doesn't seem to be enough to account for the
richness and the seemingly infinite combination of words that a
human being learns how to use. And so Chomsky
and others that came along later. So there must
be some things that are already built into the mind
. And so, yeah, maybe there's stimulus in
the environment and then there are responses from the organism
, but those responses are gonna be based on innate
structures that are already in the brain. And so
the launched a whole new paradigm, if you will
a whole new way of doing psychology which said,
we don't have to treat the inside of the organism
like a black box, right? Where you have
your input, some magic happens and then you get
an output. No, we can start looking at
those structures. And around that time also what became
popular was uh computers. So the computational devices were
becoming more and more popular. And people said,
wow, you know, computers, they, they
, they have these like internal rules and they can
, you know, give them certain kind of inputs
and they get really complex outputs and it seems like
you can mix that up and almost infinite ways.
And so that there was a marriage between these different
approaches, um artificial intelligence at the time, linguistics
and some other sub fields as well. And they
came together and they said, well, then things
like perception must also require some internal uh properties as
well. And so you can't really explain something like
detecting distance just based on the stimulus. Because for
example, if you had a little tree that was
up close to you or you had a big tree
that was far away from you, if all that
it requires for vision is the information and the environment
. Well, the little tree and the big tree
on the same line would cast the same image on
your retinal cells. So you wouldn't be able to
tell they would look the same spot. Thus,
we must have certain rules in our mind that allows
us to maybe take cues from the environment. Um
uh We see things that maybe, maybe in the
angles of shadows or something like that might tell us
that something is further away than it is closer.
So computers and the idea that you would represent the
environment in your mind and then manipulate it computationally.
This became the dominant way of doing things in the
mid 20th century. Well, here comes ecological psychology
, sorry for all the history, but you kind
of need to know some of that to, to
appreciate what Gibson was doing. A and by the
way, just to mention that in our first interview
, we talked more extensively about computational representational approaches.
So we if people want to go back there and
watch that be that bit again because it provides even
more con context, I guess to what we're talking
about here. So, yeah, exactly. Yeah
. Thank you, Ricardo. Um So Gibson said
, well, um he was, he was actually
he was a, a scientist uh in the army
and in, in the US military. And he
was um tasked with trying to help develop training better
training methods for pilots because he said pilots, they
were treating uh the environment like a Cartesian coordinate system
where it's just abstract kind of space of three dimensions
on an A season. So uh if you want
to land your plane and survive, uh you want
to think of yourself as one point in that coordinate
system and then the landing field and the plane and
another part of that coordinate system, and then you
try and calculate that. Well, it turns out
the pilots were really bad at learning to fly that
way. So he said, well, what do
pilots actually do when they land successfully? He said
they actually pay attention to what the environment is doing
in relation to themselves. And so he picked up
on the notion of optic flow as something that guides
uh the ability of pilots to land. And he
said, maybe if we train the pilots to focus
on optic flow, so that's when the environment is
moving in your your space of vision. If we
tell them focus on the optic flow of the runway
, and we try and coordinate our sense of our
body in relation to that optic flow, maybe people
will land better and it turns out that it did
, it worked out better for them to think of
things in, in that sense instead of the abstract
sense. So this is one of the early also
approaches um that became known as embodied cognition or embodied
mind, the idea that you get your sense of
body or your app proprioception and your haptic senses as
a way of gaining information about the world. And
so what did Gibson then do from this simple lesson
? He said, well, maybe, maybe the
environment actually is rich with information, maybe um organisms
don't represent the world in their minds as much as
we think they do if at all, maybe what
they do is they leverage things like optic flow or
the ambient light in a room or things like that
. And so how do we know that the little
tree is up close and the big tree is further
away? Well, we know that because of information
in the environment like parallax, the parallax is what
happens when something uh is up close. And if
you're moving, it seems like it's moving faster.
If something is far away and you're moving at the
same speed, it seems like it's moving slower.
So if you've been in a car or on a
train and you look outside and you look down and
you see the road moving really fast, but then
you look at the distance and it looks like the
mountains are barely moving at all. That's parallax.
And that information is in the environment. It's nothing
that's represented in the brain or in the mind.
So Gibson launched this whole new approach to doing perceptual
psychology based on the idea that the environment is not
impoverished the way Chomsky and the cognitive revolution uh neuros
or scientists said, but that we can actually use
the environment to um inform even complex actions. And
so from there, here's the last main bit from
there, he developed the term uh affordances. And
so I think uh this is a common term now
outside of ecological psychology, roboticists, people in education
, all sorts of different people in art design,
they use the term afford it uh loosely what it
means is opportunities to do things in the world.
So when I see this cup in front of me
with little paints of Nietzsche on it, it affords
grasping if the features of the object and my body
have a nice match, right? If the cup
is too tiny for my fingers or if it's gigantic
and I can't grab it, then it does not
afford grasping. And so Gibson said, it's likely
that any organism that is perceiving the world from a
little ant to a grasshopper to a dog, to
a chimp to a human is likely perceiving opportunities to
do things in the world. And those opportunities are
constrained by the organisms sense of its body. So
it's embodiment and then information in the environment. So
that's what ecological psychology in this case boils down to
the idea of an organism, environment system that can
act intelligently in the world based on embodiment and environmental
or ecological information. And so that's about ecological psychology
. But then how does neuroscience get into the picture
of what you explore in your book? Uh Perhaps
, I mean, we have to go through some
of the main historical developments here as well uh to
then understand why it is that psychology uh or ecological
psychology and neuroscience uh theoretically conceptually and methodologically, at
least at first sight seem irreconcilable. Yeah. So
the uh historical story that I try to tell uh
in the book is one in which you've got multiple
strands of research happening uh investigating mind in different ways
. Um So there are people do perceptual psychology,
for example, you know, there are gyps ecological
psychology, cognitive psychologists and the like and so,
neuroscience. Um uh and again, this is just
painting in broad strokes, right? So there's always
gonna be exceptions and things like that. But painting
in broad strokes, neuroscience is very much um what
I'll call it a anatomical or physiological discipline. I
was interested in what are the um the bodily constituents
of the nervous system, right? What are,
what are nerve cells? What are neurons? What
are glial cells? How do they work? How
do they act? And so fast forwarding a bit
. How do those anatomical units connect to things like
intelligent behavior or memory or problem solving? And so
, as I try to tell in the book Neuroscience
, especially things like Perceptual Neuroscience or cognitive neuroscience,
things more concerned with um the type of phenomena that
are studied in psychology, for example, um they
inherited a lot of the uh theoretical approaches from the
cognitive revolution. So the cognitive revolution sparked this approach
which uh we call cognitive and cognitive is was the
idea that cognition, uh intelligent behavior, perception,
memory, um the control of movement, co-ordinated movement
. All these things are essentially computational and representational in
nature. And So as I mentioned a few minutes
ago, the idea is that uh it's not just
stimulus from the environment and response uh from whatever is
happening in the body. And you don't need to
pay attention to what's happening in the brain, right
? The black box. But inside here are computations
that are manipulating representations. So when I speak a
language, I have representations of words and sounds,
the computations organize those in certain ways that give me
uh language comprehension, for example. So as I
argue in the book, Neuroscience inherited this way of
thinking about uh organisms as these brains or neurons or
nervous systems that are conducting computations and they're manipulating representations
of the world. And so when you think about
a computer that manipulates bits like ones and zeros,
right? So whenever you write a computer program,
it's made up of strings of ones and zeros and
certain kinds of ones and zeros give you a tiktok
video or one gives you music or one gives you
a game you're gonna play, it's all still ones
and zeros. And so the idea was that neurons
which were thought of as simple firing units. So
they either fire or they don't. So they set
off an action potential. Maybe theoretically speaking, neuroscientists
are history club, maybe those spikes can be thought
of as like a one. And when it's not
spiking, it's like a zero and so taken together
, you know, these millions and millions of spiking
ones and zeros are like the millions and millions of
zeros and ones in a computer. And so the
brain must be a kind of computational device. So
Neuroscience inherits this way of thinking about thinking uh thinking
about nervous systems as essentially a kind of wet computer
, right? It's not made out of silicon,
like my macbook, but it's made out of,
you know, cells and blood and water and proteins
and all this kind of stuff. But essentially it's
doing the same thing as a computer. Now.
Where did the split come in between neuroscience and ecological
psychology? Well, right from the beginning, right
, from the start, there's a big split and
the big split is that neuroscience inherits this view that
the environment is too impoverished to provide a kind of
information that can guide intelligent action, for example,
whereas the ecological psychologist says the environment is rich with
information which can guide intelligent behavior and action. And
so right there from the start, you have one
fundamental break that happens right there. The neuroscience test
is put in uh their, their bets on the
cognitive this theory and they're saying it's gonna be all
about what's happening in the brain or the, or
the, you know, cognitive system. The ecological
psychologist is gonna say actually what's gonna happen is it's
gonna be distributed throughout the body, which includes a
brain, but mostly the overt kind of gross body
and the environment itself. So they're coming at some
of the same targets of investigation, like visual perception
, for example, and they are coming from very
different uh starting points and theoretical commitments. And so
you see that at least since maybe the 19 seventies
or so 19 eighties, that this big split between
these two approaches and it would seem that they are
irreconcilable. They're, they're in some ways, as
I say in the book, in some ways,
they are different worlds, right? For the ecological
psychologist, the world is full of affordances and rich
information that's real, right? For the neuroscientists,
right? What's really real is what's happening in the
mind which equals the brain. And so this is
just very radical ways of, of approaching um doing
the same kind of work. And by the way
related to those theoretical slash conceptual foundations that differ between
ecological psychology and neuroscience, one of the things that
you also explore in the book, in this case
regarding neuroscience is that you talk about two different traditions
in neuroscience. And uh I would like you to
tell us about them and then perhaps explain why does
it matter in the context of your book? So
one of them is focused on biological features of neurons
that is the Hodgkin Ley tradition. And the other
one more on abstract features of neurons, the mccullough
pits tradition. So what are those traditions really about
in what ways do they differ? And why does
it matter for your book specifically? Yeah, great
, great um question. I'm glad you, you
asked that. So, as I said, the
earlier days of neuroscience that I presented in the book
and this very broad sketches, it's very focused on
anatomy uh and looking at what the anatomy itself is
like. And so uh Hodgkin and Huxley did this
pioneering work um in the, you know, mid
20th century where they created some of the earlier models
of single neuron activity. And so they looked at
uh squid neurons. Um uh squid was a a
great case because their neurons and their axons were so
big that they could actually feed them with uh very
simple microscopes. They wouldn't need these like high powered
electron microscope. So they could test the anatomy in
a in a in a in a pretty broad,
highly detailed way. And what they focused on was
what are the contributions of different kind of molecular activity
, calcium, uh things like that. Um And
what's happening when the cell is acting in a way
to say, make you know, the tentacle move
or something like that. What they found was this
is a very dynamic kind of activity, right?
This is a temporal activity, right? So there's
time before the neuron fires and there's build up and
there's activity and and say the calcium channels and things
like that in there and then it hits a certain
point and then boom, you get the spike of
activity and then it kind of dissipates and it's prepared
for another spike, right? And so this was
a very temporal kind of way of thinking about it
. So earlier days of Neuroscience, some of the
biggest achievements focused on the combination of anatomy and dynamics
or time around the same period uh in history,
you had some other pioneering work happening by a,
a couple of um gentlemen mcculloch and Pitts and what
they said was let's try and think about uh abstractly
what's happening here. So how do we um reconceive
the anatomy in mathematical terms, though not modeling the
anatomy, not modeling the activity with mathematical tools,
but thinking about what the anatomy is doing as calculating
as a kind of mathematical kind of phenomenon. So
they developed um some the earliest mathematical models of uh
neural activity. So the mcculloch Pitts model um and
they treated uh these models as simple on and off
switches, right? So the the neural network as
we come to talk about them today, neural network
models, right? It's a collection of these ones
and zeros or that these systems that are weighted,
right? And it's all mathematical. And so this
mcculloch hits of the quick little aside that work was
foundational to um the popular kind of models that we
see now known as like large language models. So
chat GP T um all these different kinds of systems
that are so popular and and and controversial in the
news lately, these are all defendants of the mcculloch
Pitts model which treated cognition and thinking as essentially kind
of like a mathematical phenomenon. It's all about calculations
. So you have these two traditions that were being
practiced. And I think it's fair to say that
the Macao Pits tradition which focused on the mathematics and
the computations and the abstraction away from the anatomy.
That's definitely the one that has become the most popular
. Again. Look at the successes of neural network
models like, you know, chat GP T and
stuff like that for the purposes of the book.
Though I point out that um and this is related
to another paper that I wrote called the Dynamical Renaissance
in Neuroscience is that while there has been a great
popularity in the abstraction away from neurons and into developing
these neural networks, there's also been a refocusing as
well on the dynamics and the timing of neural systems
. And so what we're seeing is more and more
focus on uh nonlinear dynamics, things like that um
as being essential to nervous systems. And so it's
not just about like what calculations they're producing, which
don't really matter, like how fast they go or
how slow they go. It's just a number of
steps and you can do the steps fast, you
can do the steps slow, but you get the
same output. But there's been a new appreciation for
this earlier work which I call the Hot and Huxley
tradition that says it's not just about the steps,
but it's also about how fast they happen or how
slow they happen. And so this renaissance of as
I call it and I talk about in the book
is that neuroscience is repaying attention to the dynamics of
what's happening in cognitive systems, intelligence systems and perception
. Um I forget if you had a, a
another part of your question. Uh No, no
, but I, I actually want to ask you
a follow up. So just to see if I
understood it correctly, then these emphasis on abstract features
of neurons actually something that in more recent times as
lether or at least some people in the cognitive sciences
, neuroscience and so on to a more uh dynamical
systems approach to uh cognition, psychology and so on
. Is that correct or? Well? So sometimes
. So um if I understood the question correctly,
are people who are focusing on the abstract computations of
uh neural systems of cognitive systems? Are they now
including dynamics? Um Sometimes they are but not always
necessarily and ST as vice versa, people who focus
on the dynamics are not focusing on the computational properties
per se. So there is some overlap but not
necessarily. So. Um Yeah. Mhm No,
I was just trying to really understand here and perhaps
to some extent I was oversimplifying it, but I
was uh since you mentioned the dynamical Renen in cognitive
science and neuroscience, uh I was just wondering if
really abstracting more from uh neurons for more from their
biological features, not focusing too much on them would
help moving beyond these. I don't know, perhaps
brain centered approach and uh computational representational approach to uh
cognition, neuroscience and so on. Well, it's
interesting, I think um there's people who have used
the same evidence to make different conclusions. So some
people have argued that um you know, because nervous
systems and take, you know, humans and other
mammals um because what really matters to intelligence and perception
and memory and all this stuff is the computations in
the nervous system. It doesn't really matter. Um
If it's in a mammal, it, it could
be, you know, in a bird, it
could be an insect, it could be in a
computer, it could be, you know, I
don't know, in a ghost made out of ectoplasm
or something like that. I don't know. Whereas
other people have said no, no, no,
no, no. What the nervous system is doing
is a spec you know, special kind of computation
that's, you know, specific to, you know
, brains and there's something very special about brains.
Now where the dynamics come in that just adds another
layer, right? Some people say, what's the
computations and the dynamics that prove this, what's the
computations and dynamics that prove that it's been really tough
to, to say uh who's right and who's wrong
in those debates? Mhm Yeah. A actually,
yeah. Now, now that you're mentioning that uh
you're right. So sometimes when there's discussion surrounding uh
uh the extent to which uh artificial intelligence, artificial
intelligence systems can be or become humanlike, there's that
idea that perhaps if it's uh just about computations,
I mean, the same computations can be instantiated in
silicon based uh cognitive systems as they are in carbon
based cognitive systems. Right. Mhm. I guess
. Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. That's right.
So, but then, uh, we were talking
about uh ecological psychology as well and the relationship or
the lack thereof with ecological psychology and neuroscience. But
then there's also ecological neuroscience. So what is it
? And what's basically the theoretical background behind it?
Yeah. So ecological neuroscience um is a term um
used loosely, there's no official kind of discipline called
ecological neuroscience. Ecological Neuroscience term used to refer to
people who are attempting to try and bring together uh
these seemingly disparate and irreconcilable approaches to understanding cognition and
perception. So what they wanna do, they wanna
see if the lessons from Gibson and ecological psychology can
be uh integrated with uh what we know about the
nervous system. And so you've got work um going
back at least to the 19 eighties in which people
are paying more attention uh by people. I mean
, ecological psychologists are paying more attention to the contributions
of the nervous system and brain to things like afford
its perception. Now, iii I really need to
stress um a couple of things here. So one
is that Gibson um James Gibson and his spouse Eleanor
Gibson, they were really pushing back against the dominant
approach, the dominant approach that you just, you
gotta look at the brain, the brain is awesome
and computers are awesome. And we've got all this
technology, we have put all this stuff together and
that's where, you know, we're really gonna be
explaining things and I think at least strategically, um
you know, the Gibsons especially, you know,
James Gibson and his work on perception was like,
we're not even gonna really talk about the brain,
right? We're not gonna really talk about that.
Like, of course, you know, mammals,
the chimpanzee has a brain, of course, it
has a nervous system, of course, it controls
movement with its nervous system and, and, and
, and brain. But really what matters is that
we need to really appreciate the role of the body
and the role of the environment. And so,
um by not talking about the brain and not emphasizing
the nervous system, this led a uh uh a
lot of people to think that uh ecological psychologists uh
didn't believe in brains that they ignored brains that they
thought maybe that they just didn't exist. Uh So
, for example, um Daniel Dennett, the philosopher
, cognitive scientist, uh he's get some quotes from
some writings he did in the eighties uh where he
said, you know, people like Gibson, they
treat the brain as if it's a piece of wonder
tissue it's, it's like it's magical. We don't
even need to explain really how it works or that
there's neurons. It doesn't, it's just, it's
magical. It's a magical part of the body and
it resonates magically with for ins and things like that
. Other people like Carl Pribram also in the 19
eighties. Uh He has this other uh great quote
and I say great cause it's, you know,
it's something special. He says, uh you know
, there are some ecological psychologists that acknowledge that there's
a brain and nervous system. But for people like
James Gibson, uh whether you know, there's really
that stuff on the inside or just foam rubber,
it makes no difference to their theory, right?
And so you've got Dennett who thinks uh the Gibsons
ecological psychologists are wowed by the magic of the brain
. So they don't even want to touch it or
talk about it. And you've got people like prem
and other people who are like they, I just
think that it doesn't even matter. You could,
you could fill, you know, you could just
, you know, scoop out all my brain and
fill it with rubber and it wouldn't make any difference
to my ability to perceive for since, right.
So Gibson, an ecological psychologist had a really hard
time uh with trying to explain things like perception without
doing what everyone else was doing, which was talking
about the brain and talking about complications. So,
um I think that's really important to, to,
to acknowledge that. So, ecological neuroscience was this
attempt to say, hey, we have it as
ecological psychologists really focused on the brain and specifically what
the brain is doing. Um We don't think that
it doesn't matter if it's a brain or foam rubber
, like no, no brains matter, right?
Brains matter. They're important. Are they computing like
a computer? Are they representing the environment um in
little pictures in the head? And that's how we
control things like action and my ability to grab,
you know, the avoidance of this cup. Is
it really about computing and representing? No, it's
not, but the brain is doing something. Let's
see what it's doing. So, ecological psychologists were
interested in trying to see what is the nervous system
activity that is going along with things like hance perception
and that was some of the early kind of ecological
neuroscience work. Um I can leave it at that
for now. Yeah. Sure. So uh I
, I think that we've already covered uh lots of
theoretical and historical background here. Uh I want to
get into the main thesis that you develop in your
book. I guess that before that we just need
to talk a little bit about complexity science here.
We've already talked about ecological psychology and neuroscience, how
they relate how they split historically and then also ecology
, neuroscience and traditions in neuroscience. So perhaps uh
that's enough about it if you have something else to
add about it, please go ahead. But uh
getting into complexity science, I mean, we've already
again, talked a lot about it in our first
interview. So I refer to it again. But
what role does it play in the context of the
thesis you develop in your book? Exactly. Yeah
. So um I think historically, part of the
problem with bringing together ecological psychology and neuroscience is that
they just have very different ways of talking about the
world and they have different methods and different tools that
they use. So my thinking was what if we
start bringing them together by applying a similar kind of
investigative approach. Uh AAA similar set of concepts,
a similar set of methods that both ecological psychologists and
neuroscientists can both agree on and use and maybe that
can be a way to bring them together. So
to that end, um I thought that complexity science
offered those concepts and those tools that are applicable to
the very little. So the neurons in the brain
, to the very big, just an organism acting
in the world. And so um this is not
anything especially unique to me because the fact is that
if you look at the ecological psychology literature and you
look at the neuroscience literature, there are people who
have been trying to pull little bits from complexity science
because it's such a broadly applicable set of tools.
So complexity science is um made up of a lot
of sub disciplines. But in short, it tends
to include things like systems theory. Um So the
idea from like cybernetics and things like that of the
importance of feedback loops in systems. Uh It takes
a lot from nonlinear dynamical systems theory. So these
tools that have been developed to capture very complicated um
types of temporal uh behaviors and systems, right?
And so all these different kinds of of tools have
come together into complexity science to allow you to say
I'm gonna study what the neuron is doing while an
organism is perceiving and afford it. And I can
talk about the neuron and the body and the environment
in very similar ways. I can use very similar
tools. And that's the what the role of complexity
science plays um in my approach. And so tell
us then about what you call in the book,
the next framework that is the neuro ecological nexus theory
framework. So what is it about? Exactly?
Yeah. So the uh neuro ecological nexus theory is
, you know, my attempt at synthesizing really the
best of ecological psychology, the best of neuroscience and
the tools and concepts from complexity science into a way
in which we can understand the contributions, the nervous
system to the body, to the environment and back
all under one framework. So the uh the neuro
part refers to the importance um of the nervous system
in the brain. The ecological part refers to the
importance of environmental or ecological information. The nexus part
refers to the idea that we have to find some
way to systematically connect, right, there's kind of
a flow from brains into bodies into the environment.
And back, we have to understand our task of
understanding intelligent behavior and mind is to understand that nexus
that flow between those different uh spatial and temporal scales
. And coming up with a system that makes sense
um that is, is, you know, have
scientific virtues like simplicity and prediction and things like that
. And so um this is a, a theory
um or philosophy if you will about minds, but
it's also supposed to be a scientific research program.
And so, while it has these strong theoretical and
philosophical approaches, you know, stuff from ecological psychology
, complexity theory and things like that, it also
offers testable hypotheses. And so the theory um uh
is, do you want me to get into,
can I explain uh briefly the the different hypotheses?
Y yes, of course. Yes. OK,
great. So um as a testable kind of science
of mind, science of intelligent behavior, um next
offers stick hypotheses which I'll go over briefly. And
so the first hypothesis um is that the organism environment
system is the privileged spatial temporal scale of description to
understand mind. So we wanna understand what mind is
. And I use mine loosely like refer to intelligent
behavior which could include things like perception and action,
but also you know, memory and problem solving if
we wanna understand that really, we have to pay
attention to the real time interactions going on in the
body and the environment. So the environment will always
be constraining the body, the body will always be
kind of constraining the environment. So that's the first
hypothesis. The second hypothesis is that when it comes
to the contributions of the nervous system, the most
significant contributions come from the neuralation dynamic. But when
it comes to understanding coordinative behavior or problem solving really
the action, so to say is coming from neuro
populations. So it's not in single neurons, it's
not in broad regions of the brain, but it's
in the connection of populations of neurons. And so
that's the significant target of population. The third hypothesis
is that those neuro dynamics, uh what is really
significant about them is their low dimensional activity. But
there's always gonna be a lot of activity going on
, we'll call that high dimensional activity. But when
we sift through that high dimensional activity, we will
zero in on actually a much more sim simple structure
of dynamics that are driving the behavior. So the
third hypothesis is to discover to reveal those low dimensional
dynamics in the nervous system. The fourth hypothesis is
that uh just like the brain of the nervous system
um is most significantly about the low dimensional dynamics.
So too is the body. So the body,
uh this is again, hypothesis for the body is
organized into low-dimensional synergy and so synergies are particular organizations
of the body for purposes of intelligent behavior, for
purposes of, you know, swinging a bat and
hitting a ball or dribbling a football, right?
The body organizes into certain synergies in order to perform
those actions. And those synergies are essentially those low
dimensional um kinds of coordinative aspects of the body.
The fifth hypothesis is that mind again used very broadly
, is it fundamentally emerges at low dimensional scale of
these organism environment activities. So, although there's a
lot of uh neural activity happening all over the place
, although the body is constantly moving, although there's
a lot going on in the environment, really intelligent
behavior, mind perception problem. So all these things
happen when all of that collapses into low-dimensional uh structures
. And there's a coordinations between the low-dimensional structures of
the brain, the low dimensional structure of the body
and the low dimensional structure of the environment. And
that's how we are best poised to understand the brain
body and environment contribution to those activities. And so
the final uh hypothesis is that the neuro ecological nexus
theory explains those low dimensional structures in terms of a
finite set of organizational principles. So there's not gonna
be an infinite set of um rules that guide the
organization of my body, but there will be a
finite set of rules that guide the organization of my
body, for example. So things like um critical
states, criticality is one kind of rule or principle
that guides a lot of different kinds of organization in
the brain body and environment, essentially to kind of
flesh it out a little bit. A critical state
is when you have uh a lot of high dimensional
activity that gets to a point where uh it is
balanced between disorder and order. So it's organized enough
to maintain a structure, but it's loose enough that
it can adapt. And so we call that that
comes from physics. And this is another key term
in complexity science, a critical state. And so
I think it's likely that neural activity, the body
and the environment, they reach these critical states in
order to achieve uh mind behavior activity and things like
that. And so as hypotheses, I think these
are all empirically testable, I think they all have
to be theoretically reasonable. Um But they can also
all be wrong. Uh If they were, if
it wasn't possible for them to be wrong, it
wouldn't be a science, it would just be a
dogma and that's, that's not fun. Mhm Yeah
, that, that's all great. And by the
way, I have a question saved for later on
in our conversation about the main challenges to your proposal
here. And we can come back to that.
But I wanted to ask you at this point specifically
when it comes to those hypothesis that you mentioned there
and looking at the evidence across the different cognitive disciplines
and so on at this point in time, at
least, and I hope this is not uh too
unfair of a question to ask at this point because
you're just suggesting this theory in your book. But
at this point in time, uh how much do
you think uh uh how much support do you think
they have scientifically, not only empirically but also uh
how the uh how accepted they would be theoretically taking
into account our current state of the art in the
cognitive sciences and how much work and what sources of
evidence would we need to draw from? To uh
really demonstrate that it's potentially uh true or correct?
Yeah. So um it is a fair question and
I think in one way, um I think things
are going in my favor and they're going in my
favor because uh I can interpret a lot of research
that has been done in ecological psychology in neuroscience through
the lens of a neuro ecological nexus theory. So
I can point out at research on network neuroscience that
looks at critical states, I can look at affordances
perception that's been modeled uh as synergies connected to,
you know, self-organization and things like that, right
. So I can, I can pull out these
examples, right? And I can say, oh
, so this is support for hypothesis one, this
is support for this. The hard part though is
um supporting the theory as a whole, right?
So the tough part is gonna be running maybe an
experiment that's gonna hit on all those different levels,
all those different scales and that's gonna be really hard
. So, how would I uh test the neuro
ecological nexus theory? Uh as a whole? Well
, I would, I would have to have a
subject come in. I would have to record from
their brain. I would have to record from their
body. I would have to record the environmental information
. Oh, this is just gonna be a huge
amount of data, right? It's gonna be enormous
. I mean, look at, look at the
brain, all this, you know, brain research
that's been happening the last 10 years. Uh the
brain initiative, the human brain project, they received
billions of dollars uh on the promise that in 10
years they would simulate a whole brain. Well,
it didn't happen, right? It didn't happen because
they started finding things like, well, there's actually
not just a few kinds of neurons in the brain
or a few kinds of cells. It's actually probably
a couple of 1000 different kinds of cells just in
the brain alone. So we might be kind of
worse off than we thought we were. It might
be much more complex than we thought it was.
So what we ended up seeing was a lot of
these approaches, they change their goal from, we're
gonna simulate a whole brain to we're gonna develop ways
to record data and share it with each other.
So that's just the first step, right? So
a way to, to handle all this data and
, and, and making sense of it is gonna
be a very big challenging part and that's just the
brain alone and I wanna come along and say I
wanna do that and the body and the environment,
right? It can be really hard to do,
at least in one kind of um straightforward, simple
setup that's gonna hit on all of those hypotheses.
What I'm gonna end up having to do is do
each one individually and then build up a case and
hopefully motivate that case. But again, each of
the hypotheses are hypotheses and they can be proven wrong
and it would require revising or undermining the whole project
. Um But I think there's a reasonable shot that
the hypotheses will turn out to be supported because there
is other work as I point out in the book
that supports each of the hypotheses on their own.
Does that address the, the question? Uh Y
yes, but, but then uh a follow up
to that since you mentioned the human brain project and
all of that, uh when it comes to having
a better understanding or ideally a complete understanding of how
our human cognition works, our, how, how
our psychology works. And of course, the human
brain project is or is or was not just simply
about cognition or anything like that, it was about
the entirety of the human brain. And so I'm
not sure what kinds of claims exactly people were making
about how much of our psychology we could understand through
it. But let's say that your theory is correct
in comparison to something like the human brain project.
If people were to apply it, to have a
full understanding of our cognition, how much better of
a prospect do you think your theory would be in
comparison to just having a complete mapping of the human
brain when it comes to understanding how cognition works?
Yeah. So um I think uh here's my uh
as, as they say, my hot take,
um we will not be able to explain most things
. We find interesting about cognition in mind by just
looking at what the brain is doing. The brain
is in some ways. It, it's the most
, you know, people describe it, you know
, in a cliche, it's the most complicated thing
in the universe that we know about. Um But
in, in other ways, it's not that interesting
. It's just made up of cells that are the
same as the cells, you know, in my
stomach or on my arm or that used to be
in my hair. Um It, you know,
it's just the same kind of structure of those cells
they communicate um in interesting ways. Uh the communication
, we see that kind of level of communication and
things like like beehives and ant colonies uh in cities
and the internet and stuff like that. So,
there's nothing really Irle about it. That's particularly interesting
. Um One of my um colleagues, uh Maor
Mangala, he's a neuroscientist uh uh who's highly influenced
by ecological psychology. And, and he often refers
to one of his colleagues, Damien Kelty Steven,
who describes the brain as a milkshake. And he
says that uh the brain is more like a milkshake
than it is like a computer. Uh milkshakes are
made up of fats and proteins and sugars. Brains
are made up of fats and proteins and sugars.
Uh computers are nothing like that, right? And
the swishing and swirling of, you know, the
activity in the blood and the oxygen and all that
stuff, it's more like a milkshake, right?
And so my hot take is when it comes to
understanding um you know, intelligence and memory and creativity
and coordinations. Um it's gonna have to include an
understanding of the body, it's gonna have to include
an understanding of body's en environment. Um And I
think that's something that um you know, Gibson was
really focused on. He wasn't necessarily like anti neuroscience
, right? But he was anti uh privileging the
brain that the brain is just, it's like,
you know, kind of like magic. Oh we
worship the brain, right? And, and,
and it's like we've got the little, you know
, your little soul or your little homunculus sitting,
you know, controlling everything and it's like, no
, no, no, that's not happening, right
? The brain is just an organ in the body
that plays a role as the heart plays a role
. Um you know, different things like that.
Um I was very privileged to have um the eminent
neuroscientist, uh Gary Bussi, um who's one of
my heroes in neuroscience. He's um really emphasized,
you know, dynamics and time and, and that
feature of the brain. But he endorsed my book
and, you know, one thing he said was
, um we really need to understand the fact that
the brain is just an organ, it's just an
organ in the skull. Um And it, you
know, you have to understand how it's situated in
the body. And there's a, a, you
know, a, a mutual kind of pathway between
what the body does and the, you know,
the brain does and it's not just about a top
down kind of control. And so I think it's
not my approach, you know, the neuro ecological
nexus theory, I think something along those lines is
gonna have to be true uh to explain even the
most simple of cognitive or mental phenomenon. Um And
one last little bit on, on my tirade,
um a response to your question is we already kind
of know that that project is gonna fail, not
just um practically, right? So it's not like
, OK, uh give us$10 billion over 10
years, we'll simulate a brain. OK? That
didn't happen. Uh So it failed. No,
no, even if it worked, I don't think
it would have provided the kind of uh explanations or
understanding we want because we've already done it with simpler
organism. So we've basically already done the human brain
project with uh little little tiny organism of the ce
again worm, which only has about, I think
it's like 307 neurons. And I mean, compare
that to humans that have about, you know,
I don't know what it is. 80 billion,
80 86 billion, I think, yeah, 86
billion. That's just the neurons, right? So
uh not mentioning the connections and the supporting cells like
glia and stuff like that astrocytes, but we already
know the full mapping and all the connections of a
seal again and yet we can't predict its movements.
We still don't have an ex full explanation about how
it moves and coordinates its body. That's only 300
neurons. All right. And we can't do it
with that. My thought is we can't do it
with that because it's not just about the neurons,
right? A full explanation of ac elegance, intelligent
behavior is gonna require yes, the neurons, but
also the body and the features of the environment and
that's gonna be just as important. Well, uh
I I guess that things are not looking good for
people who have brain centered approaches, but also not
for uh those sort of transhumanists who would want to
upload their brains to machines. Yeah, I mean
, we can talk about that if you want.
But I mean, my take is that that's not
a real possibility. Um the uploading of, of
the mind um if there is any uploading, it
won't be completely you. Um it may be a
feature of you but, but that's a whole other
interview. I'll have to come back in a few
months and then we can talk about transhumanism. Yeah
, I it was just me because II I have
this sort of beef with some friends. You don't
take it too seriously. So, uh OK,
so uh let me just think here. So we
were talking about the ne next uh theory that you
presented there and you also explained how it integrates ecological
psychology, neuroscience and so on. So what is
the ecological brain then? Really? Yeah. Um
And it's like, as I was writing the book
, I realized I was like already finishing the book
and I said, I don't think I've explained what
I even mean by the title and I think that
happens too often. People have really cool title and
then they, they don't explain it. I'm not
saying mine's a cool title, but I didn't explain
it. Um So in the end, um you
know, II I mentioned it um in the concluding
chapter, what is the ecological brain? Well,
the ecological brain in short is the idea that a
brain is always a part of an ecology, right
? It's not this system, it's not this machine
that you can understand it in isolation. It's not
like I can explain, you know, I have
my, you know, my phone, it's not
like I have my phone and whether I'm sitting here
in a nice temperature controlled room or I sit outside
and it's warm or I go into a, um
, a freezer that's storing meat and, and other
kinds of foods, but it's still operating the same
way. Right. The ecology doesn't matter really to
my iphone to a certain degree, right? It
gets too hot that it stops working. But,
but the brain is always a part of ecology,
the temperature of the body gravity, all these things
are acting on the brain and the brain is also
contributing to directing what ecology the body will be in
. So if I am feeling really cold, right
? And, and I'm sending information, you know
, across my body into my brain and then my
brain is now, you know, getting oh that
I'm not feeling too good. You know, my
brain might send out signals that says we need to
change the ecology, right? We need to be
in a different environment and those different environments are gonna
affect what it does, right? And I think
this is kind of the, you know, the
point that uh Bussi was saying when he, you
know, you know, endorsed, you know,
my book is that the brain is always a part
of these ecologies. The brain is not this isolated
kind of system. And so to understand what the
brain is doing, we have to understand that it
is part of that interactive kind of system and,
and to that and not to beat up on the
uh transhumanists again. But um and to beat up
on the human brain project, but that's what's kind
of missing, right? Is this lack of appreciation
of what actually should just be a really simple fact
, right? Um So in short, what is
the ecological brain? The ecological brain is the claim
that like every other aspect of organisms, the brain
too is situated and embedded in a certain kind of
ecology and that's gonna affect its functioning and what it
does. Mhm By the way, I hope this
is not a silly question. But since we're talking
about ecology here, there's also an approach coming mostly
from biology, but also nowadays, many anthropologists apply
it or use it as a framework. There is
behavioral ecology and then in the context of anthropology,
human behavioral ecology that is people look at different aspects
, different factors that differ across different ecologies and then
try to understand uh in terms of our behavioral outputs
our behavior. Uh if there's regularities in terms of
, if people are exposed to this or that technological
factors, uh if there are some tendencies to uh
develop societies with certain characteristics or they themselves as individuals
behaving in certain ways, so does uh it connect
or has any relationship to that in any way because
I was trying to understand if, um, that
aspect of biology could also play a role here or
not. Yeah. Absolutely. I think it's definitely
friendly at a minimum. It's friendly to those kinds
of approaches. Um, what you're talking about as
well. I think, um, there might be
some overlap with what I'm talking about, what you're
talking about and then with something called developmental systems theory
. And so developmental systems theory is its approach to
biology and psychology and it's come to influence um even
things like such as understand the criminal justice system um
and things like that. But the idea is always
that it's these whole systems that undergo change and adaptation
. So it's uh I'm not what you're specifically referring
to. I don't wanna say what I'm about to
say, applies to that, but this applies to
what I'm saying and what the developmental systems theorists say
they are uh anti reductionist in the sense that um
it's not just genes, for example, as maybe
the most reductionist approach to biology, it's not just
the gene that is uh driving um you know,
um in organisms, uh th the, and it's
not just the gene that is being acted on by
selective pressures, but actually, it's the gene part
of the organism, part of the environment, that
whole system is what's being selected for. So,
for example, um you know, when beavers,
um you know, they have a certain kind of
body. They exist in certain kind of environments.
They build certain kinds of dams, their teeth work
on both kinds of trees and wood in that area
. If those beaver families survive, it's because it's
the whole system that survived. It's the, the
fur, the tail, the teeth, the wood
, the water, all of that is a developing
system over time. And so it wouldn't make sense
to just focus on what is, what are the
genes doing, right? Put those same genes,
you know, in a different body or put those
beavers in a different environment and they might not be
selected for or they might be selected for. The
point is, is that it takes this whole entire
kind of system to be selected for. Is that
what you're, does this fit with what this behavioral
kind of and the anthropological stuff you're talking about?
Yes. And I guess that perhaps one of the
things you were alluding to there, I'm not sure
if directly or not when you mentioned the example of
the beaver disease, uh niche construction as well or
not. Yeah, absolutely. Um I think even
people who were the most, uh and I use
, you know, scare quotes again, the most
reductionist about biology, I think even they, um
, you know, you push them enough and they'll
say it can't possibly be just the genes. So
even so Richard Dawkins was one of the big proponents
of the gene centric approach. He also had a
book called The Extended Phenotype, right? And he
talks about how, you know, these behavioral things
that happen in the world, the use of wood
and the environment and stuff like that. He'd like
to frame it in terms of extensions of the genes
. I would just, I actually, I,
you know, I'm reading the same thing that he's
saying and I come to different conclusions. It makes
me think that gene is less important. But,
you know, that's uh the biologist. Uh Sure
. So um I, I mentioned this question earlier
, but what would you say are perhaps some of
the main challenges to your ees to your next uh
framework? Yeah. So there's uh there's challenges across
the board, right? So, um you know
, conceptually, right, um when I say mind
, what do I mean by mind? Um do
I also mean consciousness, do I just mean problem
solving? Do I mean perception action, right?
And these things are all debatable, right? So
um some people argue that perception of action is not
mind, right? It's not cognition, it's something
quite distinct, it's something that's more like me.
You know, again, I like using these quotes
. It's more like mere reflex, right? Whereas
cognition is it allows you to make decisions and intervene
on mere reflexes. So, so I've, I've
already got challenges conceptually, right? Method of logically
, how do I put these things in practice?
I talked about that a few minutes ago, right
? If the human brain project with billions of dollars
in time and thousands of scientists couldn't come up with
a full simulation of just the brain. How am
I gonna basically try and do uh an afforded simulation
from brain body and environment? That's methodologically, that's
gonna be very challenging and then theoretically right do and
this overlaps with, you know, concepts as well
, but are affordances something that need to take the
nervous system into account? Um Am I missing the
, the whole point of what Gibson was saying?
Uh this is, you know, kind of push
back. I've gotten from some ecological psychologist, right
. Affordances only exist in the environment and the organism
and where they meet and if you go too low
into the brain, then you're missing it. If
you go too high, then you're out of the
system, right? That's a theoretical issue. So
I, I think I am open to being,
you know, attacked and criticized in those three ways
. But in particular, I think um I face
criticisms both from people who I think would be friendly
um to ecological psychology. But I also faced criticisms
from people who are against ecological psychology. So people
who are friendly might be an activist. So an
active cognition or an activism is um a kind of
popular approach to understanding what it is to be an
intelligent living organism. And sometimes there's some overlap with
what ecological psychologists say, but not always. And
so there's that approach. Why not do um why
not call my book, The Inactivate Brain, right
? They might wanna say that and that they'd say
that's better than the ecological brain. Maybe I'd have
to argue with them about that. Right? Then
I also need to argue against people who are against
ecological psychology and people who are proponents of computational representational
approaches, proponents of mechanistic approaches, proponents of reductionism
, right? My book uh as I say towards
the end, uh I say something along the lines
of you might have noticed that I didn't explain anything
. I didn't describe anything about my approach with computing
, representing, I didn't describe any mechanisms and I
didn't reduce anything. And for some people, if
you miss, if you're missing out on some of
these and you're just not doing science, right?
If you're not providing a mechanistic account, whatever that
is, we could talk about that also. But
if you're not giving a mechanistic account, then you're
not giving an explanation. So I'm pushing back,
it's just, it's a different way of doing science
also that is pushing back against, you know,
more reductionist approaches. Um pushing back against mechanistic approaches
and then pushing back against, you know, the
apparent richness of the computer metaphor and a representational approaches
. So I, I've got, I've got,
I've got a line of people, they, they
, they're taking their number and they're, they're ready
to come in and get me. So I have
two questions. One about one specific thing that you
mentioned there and a follow up to the challenges here
. So you mentioned uh mechanistic explanations there and you
that many people would be dismissive of your framework if
it doesn't provide, provide them with the mechanistic explanation
for whatever aspect of human cognition we're studying here.
I guess. So um I mean, what is
a mechanistic explanation exactly, particularly for the people who
might not be familiar with this kind of terminology?
And what would be, let's say in this case
, a non mechanistic explanation? Yeah, good,
good. So this is a very big issue and
um the philosophy of science. Um And uh I
actually, I think it's a big issue in science
, the life science for practicing scientists, they should
think about this. Um So the mechanistic approach um
historically goes back to Newton and Descartes where they um
were thinking about say the solar system as a kind
of machine, right? Uh planets that are kind
of, you know, moving around in a certain
way, right? Almost like pivoting on a kind
of central piece which is the sun. Uh And
then the body of des Cartes who's famous for his
dualism, his mind, body, dualism. He
still was a great anatomist and he spent a lot
of his time studying the structures of the body and
he thought the body was very much like a like
a mechanical system. So for example, uh if
I had my hand, if I were to open
up my forearm, you'd see all these like tendons
. And if I were to pull one, my
finger would move, right? He said this is
like it's a machine, right? We are living
machines, fast forward a few 100 years. And
um the mechanistic approach in the late nineties, early
two thousands in the philosophy of science, there was
a group of philosophers who said, what do scientists
do when they try to explain something in the life
sciences, when they're trying to explain a cell or
an organism or an environment or something like that,
how do they explain digestion or memory or whatever?
And these, and these people said, well,
what they do is they, they try to isolate
as much as possible, their target, they try
to break it apart, they try to understand the
contributions of the parts and then they try to understand
what they do together. And so you have a
mechanism when you can say this is the phenomenon,
be it, you know, memory like long term
potentiation or digestion or whatever. And here's the starting
point, here's what each of the parts do.
And here's the ending point. Now you got a
memory. Now you have digested food. Now you
have a new baby, right? Um And so
this was, this is a very general sense in
which you have a mechanism. The problem that the
mechanist quickly um realized was you can't always break things
apart and give an understanding of them outside of their
context, right? If you have say, um
, you know, uh a toilet and the toilet
has, you know, a handle and the handle
lifts, the little thing on the inside which lets
the water run. And if you wanna unders,
if you want to describe the mechanism of how a
toilet flushes that handle is always just a handle,
that flapper is always just a flapper. The seat
is always just a seat and you just add them
together. But pretty much most things actually in nature
are not like that, pretty much things always require
a context and their capacities require the situation, understanding
the situation that they're in. And so this mechanistic
approach um had some problems and required some modification.
So people started including descriptions of things as being decomposable
. So coming apart uh non decomposable. So systems
that um only work when they are a complete whole
and then you also have descriptions of nearly decomposable systems
. So systems where you could kind of maybe get
an idea of what the parts are contributing. Uh
you know, things like that. This has been
of the most popular um way of understanding explanation in
the life sciences and philosophy of science. And it
, it I think it tracks well with what scientists
, especially like neuroscientists and biologists are doing. So
what would be a non mechanistic approach? Well,
a non mes mechanistic approach to explanation could be something
like a mathematical description. Um Einstein's equation uh Newton's
um differential equations of the solar system, these types
of things are not mechanistic, they have variables in
the equations that refer to real things in the world
. But when you are trying to understand how those
things interact, you're paying more attention to the relationship
of variables than you are as opposed to the specifics
. Uh So you kind of, you're abstracting away
a bit. Uh So that's one example of a
non mechanistic um approach. Um Yeah. Do,
do you think that in this particular case, if
we would have a mathematical explanation, perhaps one of
the reasons why maybe I don't know, psychologists and
neuroscience, neuroscientists, uh I mean, at least
a big number of them wouldn't be too fond of
uh an approach based also on complexity theory because I
don't know, perhaps the mathematics there is a little
bit too complicated for most people. I mean,
I, I'm not trying to claim that pe people
from those disciplines can't learn it. It's just that
perhaps they are not used to that level of mathematics
. I don't know, I think it's an excellent
point. Um And, and I think, you
know, now we're, now we're psychologizing our scientists
, right? We're trying to, and this might
require um its own kind of study, right?
The nature of, of, of scientists and what
they, they prefer, you know, we could
say again, broadly speaking, um people go into
physics because they want to understand the general principles of
how things are organized, right? They wanna understand
um you know, entropy, you know, of
, of, of the particles in a container.
But they don't really care about the specific particle.
But someone might be interested in doing chemistry because they
care about the specific chemical structure, but they care
about biology because they care about identifying the specific cells
and the organs and how those things come together.
And so there might be a tension here where someone
who's more, you know, quote unquote physics minded
might say, oh, you biologist, you care
about all those methods, details. But what are
you really telling us? That's interesting. Similarly,
the biologists you know, might be looking at the
physicist and saying all you're giving me is all this
crazy math and you haven't really told me how anything
actually worked, right? It's like taking a car
, right? Do we wanna understand how combustion works
or do we want to understand how the parts fit
together? Well, I think these are different kinds
of temperament, but my bet is that when it
comes to understanding mind, cognition, perception, memory
, all this kind of stuff, right? That
these emerge, these these properties, these abilities emerge
from highly complex systems, highly complicated systems with many
degrees of freedom, right? And keeping track of
all those is gonna be really difficult. And in
that sense, I think going the more kind of
physics route where you don't care about the location of
every particle inside the container, but you care about
general kind of patterns of behavior. I think that's
gonna give us more scientific virtue like uh manipulation,
prediction, things like that with that sound is the
physics approach gonna develop any medication. Is the physics
approach gonna help, you know, cure cancer?
II, I think it could contribute to it.
But I think in, in that way, the
kind of, you know, medical approach, the
anatomical approach, I think that's gonna benefit uh from
having someone who's more uh biological mechanistic minded, who
wants to focus on the the wet sticky detail,
right? But as we're seeing, I think there's
, you know, a co evolution of the two
to help us understand mine, it's gonna take both
approaches, but I lean towards my intuition is that
it leans more towards the physics kinds of stuff.
So let me ask you one last question then still
related to the challenges to your proposal. Because I
mean, I guess that one of the main things
that you pointed to here is the fact that you
would have to convince many different kinds of people from
the different disciplines, different theoretical frameworks and so on
. So do you think that perhaps one of the
challenges here and it, it's not only to your
framework or to convincing other people that potentially your framework
is correct, but also perhaps a broader question that
applies to the to your book in general also to
perhaps understanding why it is that different disciplines, even
though they might be focusing on similar objects of study
might diverge so much historically. Do you think that
has anything to do with how difficult it is to
have interdisciplinary in academia and the university context? Because
people are trained in specific areas, specific domains with
specific theoretical approaches, methodologies and so on. And
of course, then they have their careers and it's
based on the kinds of things they have been working
with the frameworks they have been applying. And of
course, it's also uh many times extremely difficult for
people to acquire enough knowledge, enough competence about other
disciplines and methodologies and frameworks. So do you think
that perhaps uh in the context of your book in
general? Um this is uh something that we need
, we need to take into account and perhaps presents
a big obstacle here. I think it's an excellent
point. Um I wish I had asked you to
ask me this question because it, it's it,
it is such an excellent point. Um You know
, the, the way that yeah, the way
that knowledge acquisition happens, um you know, in
, in our systems and our culture is to have
this kind of, you know, siloed, you
know, discipline, you have a, you know
, you have your Department of Physics, your Department
of Chemistry, you know, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera. Um And for good reason
, right. Because you can only do so much
. So, I'm, I'm kind of repeating a
little bit what you're saying in agreement, right?
You can only get, you know, you get
your ph getting one phd is hard enough, right
? And then getting good at it is a whole
other level, right? And making contributions and pushing
the field forward, whatever the field it is,
it's literature, history, economics, physics, right
. Getting good enough because there's so we know so
much, we have so much information that we have
to deal with just within one discipline alone. Um
How are we supposed to engage with these really complicated
difficult topics like mine, cognition, intelligence. Well
, one thing is to say um the discipline that
I do, that's the right discipline and right.
So I'm a neuroscientist and I care about biochemistry and
that's how you're gonna do it, right? That's
one way to approach it. And you say everyone
else is wrong, another way to approach it is
to say I'm a neuroscientist. I care about the
biochemistry, but I know I need to talk to
other people who do other things and I need to
make connections and you know, to see how we
connect in that way to give a more complete account
, more complete explanation. But when is that supposed
to happen? When does that conversation happen? Not
in the journals? Right? In the journals,
they just publish very specific kind of issues, right
? Very very limited, right? You look at
a neuroscience journal and they, they say, well
, we are now looking at molecule X that's an
AX on receptor 32. And this, and I
spend my whole career, you know, doing that
. Well, what does that have to do with
cognition? If anything? Right? I, I
don't know, but someone needs to be talking about
this. Uh and, and, and trying to
bring these things together, the establishment um doesn't reward
that kind of work, right? Whenever you publish
in the top journals, you're usually very focused.
When you get grant money, it's to, to
look at very specific kinds of issues where you already
kind of know how the problem is gonna be solved
. You kind of, you end up especially in
the US institutions with, with grant funding, you
kind of have to already have succeeded in your project
in order to get the money. Um and,
and, and so where's the risk and where's the
interdisciplinary when it's other people who are very specific and
focused, who are making the the decisions about whether
your grant gets funded or your paper gets published.
So the system itself makes it very difficult to um
embrace these multi scale kinds of approaches. Um As
I think my approach is, I think sometimes this
is the luxury of being a philosopher is um I
get to kind of, you know, I get
, I get to dabble in these different areas,
right? Um But I also thought at least personally
, if I want to explain or at least engage
with the sciences of the things I'm interested in like
cognition or intelligence, I think I should have had
some training to see what these scientists do. And
so I have, I have training in experimental psychology
and neuroscience because I wanted to see kind of what
the philosophers are saying. And if it makes any
sense, I wanted to see what the neuroscientists are
doing that the philosophers are right or wrong about,
but it's been really hard to do. Um And
not everyone wants to do that. Um nor should
they uh you end up getting more successful if you
focus on a limited range of things and get really
good at that. So, yeah, I think
interdisciplinary, I think um the way the system is
set up of reward in academia and things like that
, I think that's definitely poses a challenge to providing
a multidisciplinary multis scale account of very complicated phenomenon.
Mhm You know, one of the reasons why I
asked you that question is that, I mean,
perhaps uh I have a privileged position because I'm able
to do this full time. And I talk,
I get to talk with people from many, many
different disciplines, mostly the psychological, behavioral evolutionary sciences
, but also from other areas. And I mean
, I understand it's perfectly understandable that people of course
cannot learn all of these and neither can I,
I mean, I only know tiny bits of uh
everything, let's say. But, um, I
mean, it's perfectly understandable. But on the other
hand, sometimes I see a lot of people from
this different disciplines dealing with the same subjects talking past
each other just because they are not versed on what
the other people, what the other person is working
on. The kinds of theoretical approaches. They have
the kinds of methodologies, they apply uh concepts and
so on and, and, and sometimes it's really
, it, it can become really frustrating to see
that perhaps people are clinging so much to their own
. I don't know, pet theories or pet methodologies
or their own uh preferred frameworks. And just very
, and perhaps this is the part that frustrates me
the most just easily dismiss uh some other things that
or, or other approaches that other people have and
many times it's because they don't even have a good
enough understanding of what the, the other people are
coming from because again, they don't have enough knowledge
about it. I mean, ii, I don't
know if you agree with what I'm saying here or
if you, we and the criticisms of it.
No, I agree. And I'll take you one
step further and here's another hot take. I think
a lot of scientists um don't even really understand the
commitments of their own discipline. And I say that
as a matter of fact, not as a value
judgment because there is no need to question uh the
commitments, right? Um So Thomas Coon, uh
historian, philosopher of science, he talks about normal
science. Normal Science is when you have a community
of people who speak the same language, right?
So maybe we'll take a biologist, they kind of
understand what a gene is, what a cell is
. Uh They have shared methods like, you know
, basic statistical analysis. They all understand that they
all, you know, read the same journals,
they all um teach the same textbooks, right?
They all have an idea of what experiments should look
like and what an answer should look like. And
this is just normal everyday kind of science. They
don't have to question whether a gene really is exist
or whether, you know, what is a spell
or what, you know, are these statistical methods
found? They don't have to uh and they probably
as a discipline would be worse off if they paid
attention to that, they can make a lot of
progress by just accepting the paradigm, right? The
problem though is when you start hitting, you know
, at least what Thomas Coon said, you start
hitting anomalies like, right? Too many things that
you can't explain or when things get too messy,
that's when scientists are questioning their paradigm. And so
I totally understand and I totally respect uh the,
the day to day scientist who doesn't have to question
the foundation and they don't have to pay attention to
anybody else. Um But if you have that,
that tendency, if you have that personality, that
questions things, um it's very easy to find what
people don't know about even their own discipline. OK
, great. So perhaps this is a good point
to wrap up the interview. And the book is
again the ecological brain unifying the sciences of brain,
body and environment. I'm leaving a link to it
in the description box of the interview. And Doctor
Favela, apart from the book, would you like
to tell people again, where can, where they
can find you and your work on the internet?
Yeah, so you can um you can find me
. Um My website is a little bit um The
link is a little bit long. Um But I'll
ask Ricardo to post it, but it's uh Luis
H Favela one word dot Wix site, Wix si
te.com/luis H Favela. Um If you go there,
you, you can get links to my papers and
see what's, what's going on. What I'm up
to. Um You can feel free to email me
um at Luis dot fella at ucf.edu that's also um
on the website as well. Um But yeah,
and you can pick up the book at any,
any seller, books, Barnes and Nobles Amazon.
Um Yeah, glad to be here. We're uh
happy uh to talk about this stuff. No,
it's always a pleasure to have everyone. Doctor Fave
and I really love the book. So I really
hope that uh people from the audience also buy it
and read it. It's a very interesting read.
And thank you so much again for coming on the
show. And I really hope to have another chance
of talking with you somewhere in the future. So
that'd be great. Thank you, Ricardo. Hi
guys. Thank you for watching this interview. Until
the end. If you liked it, please share
it. Leave a like and hit the subscription button
. The show is brought to you by N Lights
learning and development. Then differently check the website at
N lights.com and also please consider supporting the show on
Patreon or paypal. I would also like to give
a huge thank you to my main patrons and paypal
supporters, Perera Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick Suno
Bernard Seche O of Alex Adam Castle Matthew Whitting B
no wolf, Tim Ho Erica LJ Connors Philip Forrest
Connelly. Then the Met Robert Wine in NAI Z
Mark Nevs calling in Holbrook Field, Governor Mikel Stormer
Samuel Andre Francis for Agns Ferger, Ken Herz and
Lain Jung Y and the K Hes Mark Smith Jungle
. Tom Hummel s friends, David W and the
desario Roman Roach Diego and Jan Punter Romani Charlotte Bli
Nicole Barba, Adam Hunt, Pavlo Stassi, Nale
Me, Gary G Alman, Samo Zal Ari and
Ye Polton John Barboza, Julian Price Edward Hall,
Eden Broner Douglas Fry Franca Gilon Cortez or Solis,
Scott Zachary FW Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul
Giorgino Luke Loki, Georgio, Theophano Chris. Williams
and Peter Wo David Williams Di Costa Anton Erickson Charles
Murray, Alex Chao, Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier
, Bangalore Fist Larry Dey junior, Old Einon Starry
Michael Bailey. Then Spur by Robert Grassy Zorn,
Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radis Mark Temple,
Thomas Dvor Luke Neeson Chris to Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin
Gilbert Jessica. No, Linda Brendan Nicholas Carlson Ismael
Bensley Man George Katis Valentine Steinman, Perlis Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Abert Liam Dan Biar Masoud Ali Mohammadi
Perpendicular J Ner Urla. Good enough, Gregory Hastings
David Pins of Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and Jos
Net. A special thanks to my producers is our
web, Jim Frank Luca Stina, Tom Vig and
Bernard N Cortes Dixon Benedikt Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine
and Patrick Tobin, John Carl, Negro, Nick
Ortiz and Nick Golden. And to my executive producers
, Matthew Lavender, Si Adrian Bogdan Knits and Rosie
. Thank you for all.